IRA's it the future for a living not
just one future but many possible
futures bringing back evidences from
those sutures for you to experience
today like an archaeologist of the
future
over the years my many journeys have
brought back things like a new species
of synthetically engineered bees a book
named pets s protein a machine that
makes you rich by trading your genetic
data a lamp powered by sugar a computer
for growing food okay so don't actually
travel to different futures yet but my
husband John and I spent a lot of time
thinking and creating visions of
different futures in our studio we are
constantly looking out for weak signals
those murmurs of future potentials then
we trace those cells of potential out
into the future asking what might it
feel like to live in this future what
might we see here and even breathe then
we don't experiment build prototypes
make objects bringing aspects of these
futures July making them concrete and
tangible so you can really feel the
impact of the future possibilities here
and now but but this work is not about
prediction it's about creating tools
tools that can help connect our present
and our future selves so we become
active participants in creating a future
we want a future that works for all so
how do we go about doing this
for a recent project called drone avery
we were interested in exploring what it
would mean to live with drones in our
cities drones that have the power to see
things we can't to go places we can't
and to do so with increasing autonomy
which I understand the technology
getting our hands dirty with crucian so
we built several different drones in our
studio we gave
name functions and then flew them but
not without difficulty things came loose
GPS signals glitch and drones crashed
but it was through such an
experimentation that we could construct
a very concrete very experiential slice
of one possible future so now let's go
to that feature let's imagine we are
living in a city with drones like this
one we call it the night watchman it
patrols the streets often spotted in the
evenings and at night initially many of
us are annoyed by slow dull hum but then
like everything else we got used to it
now what is you could see the world to a
size see how it constantly logs every
resident of our neighborhood logging the
kids who play football in the no ball
game area and marking them as statutory
nuisances and then see how it disperses
this other group who are teenagers with
the threat of an autonomously shield
injunction and then there's a giant
floating this called Madison its glaring
presence is so overpowering I can't help
but stare at it but it feels like each
time I look at it it knows a little more
about me like it keeps flashing all
these Brian air adverse at me as if it
knows about the holiday I'm planning I'm
not sure if I find this mildly
entertaining with just entirely invasive
back to the present in creating this
future we learned a lot not just about
how these machines work but what it
would feel like to live alongside them
while Jones like Madison and
Nightwatchman in these particular forms
are not real yet most elements of our
own future are in fact very real today
for instance facial recognition systems
ivory wear in our phones even in our
thermostats and in cameras around a
thief keeping a record of everything we
do whether it's an advertisement be
glanced at or a protest we attended
these things are here and we often don't
understand how they were and what their
consequence
could be and we see this all around us
this difficulty in even imagining how
the consequences of our actions today
will affect our future last year where I
live in the UK there was a referendum
where the people could vote for UK to
leave the EU or stay in the EU popularly
known as breakfast and soon after the
results came out a word began to surface
called regret describing people who
chose to vote for brexit as a protest
but without thinking through its
potential consequence and this
disconnect is evident in some of the
simplest things save all for a quick
drink then you decide you wouldn't mind
a few more you know you wake up in the
morning feeling awful but you just /
saying that other mean the future will
deal with that as we find out in the
morning that future you is you when I
was growing up in India in the late 70s
and early 80s there was a feeling that
the future Bulls needed to include
actually be planned I remember my
parents had to plan for some of the
simplest things when they wanted a
telephone in our house they needed to
order it and then wait wait for nearly
five years before it got installed in
our house and then if they wanted to
follow my grandparents who lived in
another city they needed to book
something called a drone call and then
wait again for hours or even days and
then abruptly the phone would ring it's
2:00 in the morning and all of us would
jump out of a beds and gather round
before shaking into it
discussing general well-being at 2:00 in
the morning today it can feel like
things are happening too fast so fast
that it can become really difficult for
us to form an understanding of our place
in history
it creates an overwhelming sense of
uncertainty and anxiety and so we let
the future just happen to us we don't
connect with that future we treat our
future selves of a stranger in the
future as a foreign land with a foreign
land is unfolding right in front of us
continually being shaped by actions
today we are that future and so I
believe fighting for a future we want is
more urgent and necessary than ever
before we have learned
but one of the most powerful means of
effecting change is when people can
directly tangibly and emotionally
experience some of the future
consequences of their actions today
earlier this year the government of the
United Arab Emirates invited us to have
them shave their country's energy
strategy all the way up to 2050 based on
the government's economic data we
created this large city model and
visualized many possible features on it
so as I was excitedly taking a group of
government officials and members of
energy companies through one sustainable
future on our model one of the
participants told me I cannot imagine
that in the future people would stop
driving cars and start using public
transport and then he said there's no
way I can tell my own son to stop
driving his car but we were prepared for
this reaction working with scientists in
a chemistry lab in my home city in India
we had created approximate samples of
what the air would be like in 2030 if
our behavior stays the same and so I
walk the group over to this object that
Emeth vapour from those air samples just
one wave of the noxious polluted air
from 2030 brought home the point that no
amount of data can this is not the
future you would want your children to
inherit the next day the government made
a big announcement they would be
investing billions of dollars in
renewables we don't know what part of
future experiences played in this
decision but we know that they've
changed an energy policy to mitigate
such a scenario while something like air
from the future is very effective and
tangible the trajectory from our present
your future consequence is now always
Selenia even when a technology is
developed with utopian ideals the moment
it leaves the laboratory and enters the
world it is subject to forces outside of
the creative control for one particular
project we investigated medical genomics
the technology of gathering and using
people's genetic data to create
personalized medicine we were asking
what are some of the unintended
consequences of linking our genetics to
health care
to explore this question further we
created a fictional lawsuit and brought
it to life through 30 even pieces of
carefully crafted evidence so we build
an illegal genetic clinic a DIY carbon
dioxide incubator and even bought frozen
mice on eBay so now let's go to their
future where this lawsuit is unfolding
and meet the defendant Arnold man Arnold
is being prosecuted by this global giant
biotech company called dynamic genetics
because they have evidence that Arnold
has illegally inserted the company's
patented genetic material into his body
how on earth did on earth manage to do
that well it all started when Arnold was
asked to submit a saliva sample in this
fit kit to the nhi the UK's National
Health Insurance Service when Ana
received his health insurance bill he
was shocked and scared to see that his
premiums had gone through the roof
beyond anything he or his family could
ever afford the state's algorithm had
scanned his genetic data and found the
risk of a chronic health condition
lurking in his DNA
and so Arnold had to start paying
towards the potential costs of the
future disease potential future disease
from today in that moment of fear and
panic Arnold slipped through the city
into the dark shadows of this illegal
clinic for treatment a treatment that
would modifies DNA so that the state's
algorithm would no longer see him as a
risk and his insurance premiums would
become affordable again but Arnold was
caught and the legal proceedings in the
case dynamic genetics versus man began
in bringing such a future to life what
was important to us so that people could
actually touch see and feel its
potential because such an immediate and
close encounter provokes people to ask
the right questions questions like what
are the implications of living in a
world where I'm judged on my genetics or
who might claim ownership to my genetic
data and what might they do with it if
this feels even slightly out there or
far-fetched
today there is a little-known bill being
passed to the American Congress known as
HR 1/3 1/3 preserving
no awareness program at this fair
proposes to amend the genetic
information non-discrimination Act
popularly known as Gina and would allow
employers to ask about family medical
history and genetic data to all
employees for the first time those who
refused would face large penalties in
the work I've shown so far whether it
was drones or genetic crimes these
stories describe troubling futures with
the intention of helping us avoid those
features but what about what we can't
avoid today especially with climate
change it looks like we are heading for
trouble and so what we want to do now is
to prepare for that future by developing
tools and attitudes that can help us
find hope hope that can inspire action
currently we are running an experiment
in our studio it's a work in progress
based on climate data projections we are
exploring a future where the Western
world has moved from abundance to
scarcity we imagine living in a future
city with repeated flooding periods with
almost no food in supermarkets economic
instabilities broken supply chains what
can we do to not survive but prosper in
such a world what food can we eat to
really step inside these questions we
are building this room in a flat in
London from 2050 it's like a little time
capsule every reclaim from the future
you stripped it down to the bare minimum
everything we lovingly put in our homes
like flat panel TVs Internet connected
fridges and artisanal furnishings all
has to go and in its place we are
building food computers from abandoned
salvaged and repurposed materials
turning today's waste into tomorrow's
dinner for instance you've just finished
building a first fully automated Fox
phonics machine so it uses a technique
of fork phonics so just fog is a
nutrient not even water or soil to grow
things quickly at the moment you've
successfully grown tomatoes we will need
more food than what we can grow in this
small room so what else could be forage
from the city insects pigeons
Fox's earlier we brought back air from
the future the Samuel bringing an entire
room from the future a room for my hope
tools and tactics to create positive
action in hostile conditions spending
time in this room a room that could be
our own future home makes the
consequences of climate change in food
and security much more immediate and
tangible what we are learning through
such experiments and our practice and
the people we engage with is that
creating concrete experiences can bridge
the disconnect between today and
tomorrow by putting ourselves into
different possible futures by becoming
open and willing to embrace the
uncertainty and discomfort the such an
action bring we have the opportunity to
imagine new possibilities
we can find optimistic futures we can
find path forward we can move beyond
hope into action it means we have the
chance to change direction a chance to
have our voices heard a chance to write
ourselves into a future we want other
worlds are possible thank you
[Applause]
you